let's see if we can tidy this up a
little bit what do I get out the front
here what is this we've tried over four
come on like in multiple numbers I know
it's late in the afternoon but they're
nice neat numbers what a thousand fifty
thank you very much
this guy up in the numerator you can't
do very much with that at the moment so
I'll just leave him be
what out the denominator so your printer
five okay now that's just a number
that's a number so I actually don't know
what this is what's a thousand fifty
divided by 0.05 they don't got it
21,000 exactly okay I came up with great
numbers that's nice
there you go there's my expression for a
of M is that okay and again the question
might have said instead prove that the
expression for the amount in mr. whose
account at the end of n years is that I
might have done that okay quick note
before I move on remember I said to you
at this point over here I could have
come up with a different GP excuse me by
factoring out the 1000 times 1.05 can
you see why I did it
why I didn't bother because in the
formula it does that anyway right so you
will come up with exactly the same sum
of a GP as I have even if we have
different GPS identified okay um why
don't I do this what was the question
again have a look and see how you use
this tool that I've just fashioned for
us to answer this I want to get to
$30,000 right that's where I want to go
okay so therefore I want this to equal
$30,000 so I'm going to say let's make
this guy 30,000
like so that make sense in tracking I've
just done a straight substitution in
there and now I'm trying to solve what
am I trying to solve for I just sold fan
thankfully because of all this work that
I've done it's the only bless you Pro
numeral left so I'm just gonna rearrange
until I get to that point okay let's see
here let's tidy this up a little bit
cancel okay it's all thirty on twenty
one is ten on seven yeah
equals this how's that it's my
arithmetic okay I want to get this guy
making the subject so I guess I will add
one to both sides which I think makes it
this how's that what do I do with things
like this I'm going to have to use logs
at this point right to get to that power
so I guess I would write N equals log
base which one's the base again the base
in this equation is the base from the
previous one remember that so that's one
point zero five down the bottom and it's
17 on seven up the top you have a
calculator you can use change of base
law I'm gonna choose base E cause I'm
lazy and I like to write Ln
and your calculators gonna hand you
something out this right cuz I certainly
don't know the answer
there's someone got a number can I have
some decimal places eighteen point one
eight six dot okay so pause for a moment
and put down your pen every time you get
to one of these spots where you're like
oh I got a number it's finished it's
simplified I got the calculator told me
something you have to pawned out what
does this mean for the actual question
that I've been asked okay
why am I getting a decimal place because
I'm expecting like a particular year why
am I getting a decimal place yeah that's
right I've gone for some fictional point
in time where I hit exactly thirty
thousand dollars but there is no such
time remember we talked before I'm using
a continuous model to try and solve a
discrete problem so therefore at what
point it says determine how many years
after how many years will I get to the
thirty thousand will I get it after the
eighteenth year
here's a of n right if you put 18 in
here you'll get a number out right but
because it's going to be less than this
it's going to be less than 30,000 right
just a little under I'm guessing
okay but I don't get a little there I've
got to wait a whole year before I get
there right so therefore my answer would
be after 19 years I'm trying to make a
big deal out of this because this is not
rounding you're not rounding it just
since when did eighteen point one eight
round up to 19 okay but you're
interpreting the question and you're
recognizing Oh what do I do with this
number to get the actual answer that I
want just for kicks in this side of the
room can you put in 18 into that formula
and can you guys do 19 for me thank you
thanks Aaron who's got 19 michael six to
five zero six five sorry gotcha
I'm okay with that so are you happy like
in calculus this is one of the nice
points where you can test whether you
got this right because you can see now
that 19 years does that seem like a
short-timer a long time to you does it
work with my sense check from before
it's under 30 years hooray my money
actually did something while I was there
not hugely faster but that's because
$1,000 isn't that much per year and 5%
isn't that much interest so that's why I
actually invest more than that annually